one time about two years ago gave
testimony in front of a senate committee
for Business and Entrepreneurship and he
was representing minority and Veteran
owned businesses so everyone please
welcome
Ruby so
imagine imagine former or ex burglar
going through your house right roaming
around inspecting going through your
stuff every looking cranny right sounds
scary ain't it well back in
2007 uh there was a hold on second let
me see I don't see
my I don't see my notes
here okay how do I get my
notes yeah go without the notes all
right 2005 2007 there was a show in
Discovery Channel that was called it
takes a tee right these are former folks
that used to break into houses right and
what they did is they uh with the
alization or permission of the owner of
the house they will actually go into
these houses and do what they do what
they did best right break in and uh
cause chaos and take stuff with them
then what they did is they they will of
course return it some of the stuff they
probably wanted to keep but they return
it and get with their families and they
will actually show them
what they did how they actually saw the
house why they picked the house because
before they do this they actually go to
the neighborhood and say that's the
house that I want they go to that owner
and ask them then once they do that they
actually show them okay this is what you
do this is the kind of lock that you
need to get and I look at this when I
look at you know I hear a dog this is so
um that perspective is um you know defin
you you got to look at things from that
perspective right in this case uh this
the we do have a a a digital that's the
physical side we have our digital house
right this uh what I'm going to speak
today about is a digital footprint so
that uh you have uh digital Invaders
that can go out there and go after you
know getting through your windows right
noon intended your door your front door
and getting to uh your house digital
house and they do that through your
footprint your digital footprint which
is your online you know online payments
your online actions like emails and uh
anything that you do online right um So
based on
that
uh you
go why is this guy talking to me about X
burglar and break-ins
and who the hell is he right what's his
deal well I I spent 23 years working for
the government I was in Special
Operations on
intelligence and uh another 14 years
working uh supporting the
government uh going after some really
bad people right and then I spent uh so
it's a total like four Decades of uh me
working as
a when I was in the government actually
went after some really really bad folks
right U some hardened CRI criminals
terrorists
um Crim uh terrorists and and U
traffickers narcotics trafficers so you
hear the accent right back in the day
that's where I worked a lot worked down
in South America because I knew knew the
culture knew the language and that's how
I got my got started so these folks are
very very uh paranoid right so of course
they're very security conscious they're
very very hard
to to get into right to to to get to
them right not necessarily their Network
to but to get to the top guy or top girl
in that case because we they have
females some
point um so how do you get there how do
you break
in weakest weakest link there's always a
weakest link right and in this case it
was either
their thugs co-workers colleagues
whatever you want to call them
especially families right South America
it was the wife the girlfriend you know
and the wife will talk because she's mad
because she went he went with a
girlfriend on that weekend on the long
weekend right and you actually get a lot
of information that way right so you
know Middle East more than one wife many
wives and so you get to uh you get to
people through not necessarily directly
but through their Network and you're
going to see the theme come along as as
as we talk right so very familiar to us
all of us right we have we have a
network we have weakest we got weak
links I used to in my house in my
network had three kids and I hated it I
couldn't wait for them to leave the
house and they finally did because you
know they do all kinds of stuff in it
and uh bring friends and and my network
was a mess and I was very I'm very OCD
right with stuff like that and know so
you can imagine uh
so let's go into a case study here see
how much I got here
uh Jane this is uh summer to
right uh well let me go back
the let me go back to something here
actually sorry I have don't have my
notes but
um we do work for so that way I can give
you a better perspective on how I'm
talking what I'm talking about here we
have done as a company nowadays right
back in the day I used to do that still
do that we still train people to go out
and do those things out forward um I'm a
for the last seven years we've been
working with uh corporate uh clients and
high high
value High net worth individuals right
and the issues that these folks have um
their security issues are basically the
same issues we all have and you all have
right uh the main thing here that I want
to bring home is awareness right because
I'm not here to tell you uh not I'm not
a a a a software engineer my perspective
is I'm not a software engineer I'm not a
computer geek I love computers I'm a
computer geek but I'm not a computer uh
you know Tech wizard that can go in
right now on Linux I still kind of rusty
on those on those uh commands but what
really is going to save you the
perspective that I'm going to give you
here is that is
awareness and it's also a way a way of
thinking right a way how you how you
actually
uh a mindset a mindset is what's gonna
you you gotta get out of who you are
actually look at things from a different
perspective and we work with corporate
clients we actually
uh silicon B companies and phds and
folks that actually are security folks
for these large companies and I learned
through the years of doing this that
people don't have the mindset there a
mindset you think I have mindset well I
grew up in Puerto Rico in really bad
neighborhoods and
uh I there were you know I grew up with
thugs with gang members um so to
survive you actually have to have a
mindset you have to have
uh you have to be paranoid right and
there's a healthy paranoia right I'm not
saying you need to be like you know
going crazy go get in the corner and
your thumb in your mouth and you know
but you got to have that healthy you get
you got to look at things completely
different I always kind of see okay that
changed what happened there who is this
why is this coming this way um so uh
that's the mindset I'm talking about
right so once if you don't get anything
out of this that I'm talking about today
is is that right forget about the
technical stuff uh forget about all the
highspeed technical talk it's about a
mindset
okay so now case study we got Jane 2019
uh this actually happened Summer she
works in a midsize company she's a CPA
she's having her uh cafe latte macchiato
with you know oat milk and and a Splenda
right and she gets an email from uh from
her bank saying hey uh security breach
we need you to come in and through this
through this link right here and you
need to update your your security
settings so you're log in right and of
course I seen those emails to right we
get them all the time and they're
getting better and better I mean and
this is my business and I actually
almost I've done it myself too right so
this lady actually clicked on the link
because she's very responsible right and
she goes uh please click on it and
putting her credentials
right H and did I say that this was a
herw computer
right
well this thing turned into a different
kind of day right uh a day later her
bank accounts were empty and not only
that she actually the digital footprint
let uh the Cyber criminals that actually
set up a website that was you know and
that that's you've seen it out there
there's good work out there they
actually uh these folks actually set a
website for the bank so real that it
fooled her fool a bunch of other people
but the issue here is that it also
affected her business he led that that
digital Trail LED those cyber criminals
right to her company so they got in and
they got uh confidential information as
well as financial information so it
caused chaos right
uh so this could also not only affect
people affect the business right um and
I have I also have I mean I only have 20
minutes for this so I could I cannot go
into all the the business side of the
house the case study for this year like
you have T-Mobile T-Mobile had I don't
know it's like was it like 30 million uh
customers that got a compromis Equifax
back in 2016 that was like 147 million
customer probably were affected by that
right and all these things just like uh
um like when I talk about the targets
that we have back in the day
uh you they didn't get to the company
directly they go with services or third
party vendors there's two this year that
happened that you probably can can
Google move it and there's another
they're they're file transfer companies
that's all they do they provide secure
file transfer services for many
companies including healthcare companies
government actually I believe one of
them provided uh for Oregon and the
Louisiana DMB right and just because
they were using that service that got
hacked and then the big company gets
hacked right so just like that guy right
that's a bad guy that's really hard to
get too it's okay I can getting through
other areas Target back in the day they
actually got hacked through what the
hbac system the that provided hbac for
for Target they got in there
right so back in the day when I used to
travel for this trips right as an
American uh you know I and I go to very
specific places I didn't really go to
all the the very nice vacation spots
sometimes you did but uh when you went
to these places being an American and
you're being a foreigner not only I had
to keep uh an eye on things and be fully
aware uh but it's just as being a
foreigner you were a target of criminals
for robberies for kidnapping in some
places they love that in South America
and some places and even worse right so
what do you do to counter that what you
do
is you change right you try to establish
uh you don't establish
U patterns right so you don't go to the
same places
all the time you change your routes you
become pretty much unpredictable right
because um if you don't go to a safe
place all the time if you don't go to
you know when you go to the library when
you go to whatever the supermarket use a
different route when you go out there
and this is on the physical R right only
and and back in days it was more about
that well today is about that and also
they track you through the virtual world
right so
um so what you want to do so there
something that another thing that you
want to take out of here is that you
want to be just like
that you don't want to be the slowest
one right you want to be the not the
fastest but you want to be the actual at
least you want to be ahead of that L the
one that's so if you start doing these
things where you're actually uh
establishing things are don't make you a
Target because that was a Target too
even though you're doing these things
you're still a Target but you're less of
a Target that's the key right uh and you
also don't want to be the lowest hanging
fruit right and we'll go into some of
that what things you can do online to
not to do that but everything everything
applies right whatever you do in the
physical world also applies to that so
you don't want to be the lowest hanging
fruit and you don't want to be as slow
as
gazelle digital footprint so when we
think of footprints we think about those
those imprints on the on the sand the
ground right or fingerprint right that's
only for you that's a profile right back
in the day when we used to go after
these folks we created Target packages
we have profiles you know alas names the
wife the son the everybody that worked
for them and now you have also a cyber
side to it right uh and there's things
that you don't probably don't even think
about that can be tracked and are
tracked
um we had a a Target we had a customer
was actually law enforcement agency here
in the states and they had this one guy
and you know all your phones and cameras
have a thing called XF is is actually
metadata right that comes with every
picture every time you take a picture
unless you change the settings on your
phone this will have time date um has a
resolution a lot of information on that
picture picture but it also includes if
you don't change the settings the
location and even the angle where you
took that picture from right that
happens by the fall right so back in the
day this was years ago so nobody was
really looking at that so this guy
actually puts a picture out online and
send it to somebody to an asset at this
time and uh of course he was showing his
money he had all his money in the
picture and the girls in the back and he
was actually hij in some Marina
somewhere and the the the the agents
were like where the hell is this place
so we took the picture he told us where
not only that but he told us okay it it
was taken from this angle at this
location so oh there's a boat oh that's
the boat right there and that's that
building that we saw behind it guys got
captured and of course a bad guy off the
street
yay but think about it now your mom your
kids your sister your brother they have
the that same capability in their phone
so it means that they're predictable
they're vulnerable right people that you
love people that you you know and
yourself right so that's just with a
picture one picture that's all it takes
we even had a a target one time where we
looked at a uh
playlist Spotify Pandora playlist and
because there some people that like very
specific kind of music and we found that
like yeah that's him right
just a playlist that's that kind of
confirm right who he was so we
definitely have a profile
pattern uh these companies Facebook I
don't know if you've seen that
documentary on Netflix I think it is
where they do have patterns on you right
these folks have like profiles on you
Instagram Facebook all these folks right
so yeah they use it for for some uh to
sell it
all information but other folks can do
use that as well right so you got to be
mindful again it's about the data and
what can you do about it to control it
right it's going to be out there no
matter what there's some things that you
cannot control but there's some things
that you can it goes back to mindset
again and
awareness so all right let's get to the
let's get to it uh if you don't get
anything out of here today is another
thing that you can get right my top four
rules for and these are not techy rules
this are four top rules of cyber
security convenience equal vulnerability
if it's easy for you it's easy for that
uh for the hacker for that person that
wants to go after you right so hey a
password right yeah just make a password
right yeah if it's easy for you they're
gonna be able to guess it so anything
some another thing oh man too time too
time to I gotta get a text every time I
log into my email oh no that's too much
that's that's inconvenient okay yeah do
it don't use it make it convenient for
you right although everything by by
default all these companies your cell
phone every everybody wanted to be
convenient right but that's not good
right prebs are always goodies uh by I
mean I mean by that is if it's free if
Uncle Sam didn't pay for it or it came
out of taxpayer money you are the
product right so any free apps anything
out there that they give you for free
there's there's there's a catch always
right uh her emails right we all
probably have a Gmail account they're
free yeah jahoo AOL some people have uh
Hotmail right you are the product and
it's like wow how these people are
making billions of dollars and I'm not
paying a penny for any of this stuff
it's free Facebook is free Instagram is
free every time you do a search on
Google right you are the
product going back to another thing that
didn't talk about like uh your vehicle
like uh Tesla right or you can buy any
car today any car that you buy today
connects to the internet right and and
it's about information from you they
probably make more money Tesla is
actually H an information company right
they're more about data on people than
they're about cars right
so location location location look at
where you connect to the internet right
if it's free
Wi-Fi there's something that comes with
it caes we used to train our our
operatives in C in in in cafes right so
people will sit there all day long and
it makes it easy for you to practice
right H that's perfect so when you go to
a cafe just be aware mindset right
mindset so um airports train stations uh
airbnbs uh and your home actually we did
a a red teaming uh for a large
corporation we actually follow a
a Somey a CEO large company well-known
guy uh and we wanted to see if we could
break into his his stuff we couldn't of
course do it while he was in his company
headquarters in San Francisco but when
he went home we follow
him the F settings in his router as at
home so not only we got into him we got
into his devices got into all his family
and we also got tools into the his
device and his computer so next morning
when he brought those back to the his
headquarters now we own the network
right so look at things like that you
know not necessarily looking at
technology doesn't have to be high speed
it's about mindset look at where the
vulnerabilities are hackable breakable
and manageable Everything Is hackable
Right everything don't think that just
because you have a phone that has a a uh
you know High speed uh you know IRS
check uh it doesn't mean anything right
everything eventually gets hacked it it
just means that you know just because I
got an Apple computer it doesn't mean
anything it's hackable too it's just
that they make more money going after
Windows because there's more Windows
computers out there right so it's about
money
right do I
have good morning one more minute all
right so some strategies here privacy
settings and this is something mean
there's many things but this is from
what we teach to folks that go out
forward and travel in the government
operatives folks that go dark on the
internet because it's far of their job
privacy settings vpns use them right use
vpns they work uh don't use cerski stuff
okay uh double up on security that means
that that two two Factor two time two
Factor authentication yes it's a pending
the butt you go in there oh I got I got
to put this code in there it adds you
can sleep well at night because you got
that extra layer of security right you
don't want to be that that Target don't
be that gazelle right
passwords my God big one we used to love
when somebody use the same passwords
everywhere right don't use the same
password use one password I use I use
one password right it's tool use a tool
that will actually do that for you
uh back up your data you know probably
goes on set but it's be very important
because now you got run someware out
there and and yeah you still probably
going to click on that thing you on that
link well if you do click on that link
at least your data is backed up and you
can say yeah no I'm not going to give
you all that money I'm just going to
back on my computer and keep going right
and don't click on it again right uh
secure home Riders go to your rou and
Google it fix it don't leave it in
default settings that's the worst and
say up upware uh upgrade your
firmware uh be your own cyber detective
look at yourself from the outside it's
mindset right you got to look look at
yourself and say okay if I was targeting
myself what would I go on the internet
lock your credit right all those things
there's tools out there there's services
that that they're provided for you and
we're the worst folks are technical
we're we're really bad we have operat
trips are really good they good hacking
all the people it's just like that
mechanic right when you look at this car
it's really bad and then uh education
learn go out there and learn and uh
educate yourself plenty of information
so that's it please be go out there and
be a cyber Warriors and uh just
hopefully you learn something today that
was a different perspective from the
technical side
right